Salut ! Maintenant c'est devenu une habitude, vous savez, tous les jours je vous donne une énigme,
et le lendemain je vous donne la réponse, et on se fait ça pendant 32 jours.
Ce sont les énigmes de l'été.
Hier, plus qu'une énigme, je vous ai donné un défi à résoudre
avec les piles dans les fourches des pouces.
Si vous n'avez pas vu le défi, allez voir d'abord la vidéo parce que là je donne la solution tout de suite.
Par rapport à toutes les contraintes que je vous avais donné, la plupart d'entre vous ont dû se retrouver bloqués à ce stade là.
A ce niveau là.
En réalité il y a vraiment une méthode pour les saisir entre pouces et index, sans quelles ne se touchent, et sans les tenir par d'autres doigts.
Je vais passer derrière la caméra et vous allez voir comment ça se passe !
On va garder à peu près le même geste.
Une main parallèle au sol, et l'autre perpendiculaire.
Sauf que lorsqu'on arrive ici,
le pouce, au lieu de prendre ici,
va venir se coller là.
L'index est ici.
Juste là.
Donc je vous refais le geste lentement.
Au lieu d'arriver comme ça,
mon pouce vient au fond,
et l'index ici.
Le pouce droit, est bien positionné.
L'index va chercher l'autre coté.
Et on a plus qu'à les ressortir.
C'est très agaçant pour ceux qui ont des problèmes de motricité.
Mais c'est très amusant à faire.
Et surtout, ça n'a rien à voir avec l'énigme d'aujourd'hui !
C'est une énigme d'objet, retrouvez l'objet en question.
Un indice, chez vous.
Il n'y a pas d'indice, mais j'avais envie de me prendre un peu pour Julien Lepers. [rires]
"Celui qui me fabrique me vends,
celui qui m'achète, ne se servira pas de moi,
et celui qui se sert de moi, ne le sait pas, il l'ignore complètement."
Qui suis-je ?
Vous devez retrouver un objet suite à cette phrase, qui rejoins toutes ces conditions.
"Celui qui me fabrique me vends, celui qui m'achète ne se sert pas de moi, celui qui se sert de moi ne le sait pas"
Cherchez bien, vous pouvez en parler dans les commentaires,
mais si vous avez la bonne réponse ne la dites pas,
pour que les autres puissent chercher.
Donc il ne faut pas spoiler les autres.
Par conter, si vous avez trouvé, mettez un pouce en l'air, comme ça on verra proportionnellement
le nombre de pouces en l'air, par rapport au nombres de vues, pour savoir combien de personnes ont trouvé.
Passez un très bel été. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaine si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Voire même, partagez ces énigmes pour ce jeu de l'été.
Il nous reste encore 20 jours comme ça.
Puisque là aussi je vous rappelle, je suis en train de prendre des vacances au moment où ces vidéos là sont diffusées.
Et sinon le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an !
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H !
Ciao !